this is the Jocko underground podcast
Echo Charles sitting here with me
Jocko willink
how to win arguments
seems like something people would want
to know
and if that hits you if that's one of
those topics you say oh yeah here we go
this is really for you
it's really for you and there's some
people that were like well I don't seem
to argue that much good
good for you because step number one to
winning arguments
is not to get in arguments
right and here's the thing
who gets in more street fights somebody
that's a skilled martial artist that
trains Jitsu boxing Muay Thai and
wrestling
or someone that is insecure about
themselves and someone that is
intimidated by other people and someone
that feels they need to prove their
point to someone else who gets more
street fights
we know
so if you hear this question you're like
oh yeah I definitely need to know
because I'm in arguments a lot this is
already an indicator that we're probably
in the wrong spot you are probably in
the wrong spot because you're the person
that's out getting street fights why are
you getting into street fights because
you're insecure you don't feel confident
you don't actually have skills so you're
throwing Haymakers in the street
so
we don't want to be arguing with people
how do we avoid arguments
how do we maneuver around arguments
a bunch of things and this is a long
this is that we could talk about this
forever and I've been talking about this
a lot obviously a lot of this ties into
the indirect approach right and here's
the thing here's the thing
the indirect approach as soon as you say
it some people like oh I can see
weakness right oh if you're if you're if
I could do something that's out of line
I just need to go direct and tell them
to stop it and you think that's more
efficient and you think that's tough and
it's dumb it doesn't work good
it doesn't work
may you occasionally get there
can someone do something that's so out
of line that they need to be directly
confronted yes it does happen it happens
one percent of the time just like in
combat one percent of the time and look
we don't have any choice we got to do a
frontal assault on this enemy position
this is the only option we have we have
to take this position this hill this
this beach head we have to take it in
order to win we the only option we have
is a frontal assault so here's what
we're gonna do that happens one percent
of the time one percent of the time Echo
Charles is so out of line or whoever is
so out of line that you have to say hey
stop
you can't do that you have to take the
direct approach by the way
if it's people you're interacting with
you should build a relationship with
them where they already know not to take
that approach so that's like the way to
win we're doing trying to do all these
things we're trying to win without
having to fight the best way to win an
argument is the other person doesn't
even know there was an argument taking
place that's how we're looking to win
that's what we want to do so here's some
little things to think about as you go
through your day
look for common ground with other humans
what what common ground can I find
because if you're on one side and I'm on
the other side of the Abyss we're not
together we're not agreeing on things
and we can't even reach across the abyss
because it's too big
so I'm looking for some common ground
I Look to start off when someone wants
to discuss something with me which means
they want to argue something with me my
first effort is to agree with some point
that they're bringing to me
and I'll actually agree with them
harder if I can
harder than harder than they came at me
I'm gonna take an even harder
approach on myself right I had somebody
I was talking to somebody the other day
and they were bringing up the fact
that America hey America is evil
not quite evil but America's evil
and they brought up the Abu ghraib
prison Scandal right where the people
were taking the soldiers were taking
pictures of them stacking them up
doing putting them in uncomfortable
positions they brought that up
I agreed harder than that I go wait
that's nothing compared to the milai
massacre that's nothing compared to the
Sand Creek so I took their point and
emphasized it even harder and yeah so
now I'm even more on their side than
they are right right that's good I
crossed that abyss and got to their
flank before they even could say another
point
so I'm looking to agree if I'm looking
for something to greet guess what I need
to do I need to listen to what they're
saying I need to truly listen to what
they're saying and as I'm listening to
what they're saying
that's when I can get to find something
that we can agree on that I can build a
little foothold that I can start to
build a relationship with them where
they see that I'm on their side and then
they can start to listen to what I'm
saying because before that if we're on
the opposite sides
we can't get across the abyss we're just
going to argue how
we've had this conversation before about
social media I think I actually said it
on on Rogan's podcast like how many
times has someone on Twitter
said you know what great point I really
appreciate you sharing that perspective
I've changed my mind like that doesn't
happen and it doesn't happen it happens
so rarely
it happened so really that means this is
an ineffective approach that's the
direct approach so actually you're wrong
in the past 14 months there's been this
many whatevers whatever whatever I hit
you with some facts and you go oh thank
you for pointing that out I really
appreciate it now I've been enlightened
and now I've shifted my mind that
doesn't happen
so we're not doing that because we don't
make real progress our ego might feel
good
that I told you what was up
so instead think about how you can
find some common ground listen to what
people have to say agree with what
they're saying
agree harder if you can which is
actually not as hard as it sounds you
make some point to me I'll probably I
can probably think of a more extreme
example of what you're talking about and
talk about how I do agree with that's
wrong yeah and then we want to look at
the way that these things are framed how
can you frame things with people
so that they see them from a different
perspective uh how do you take a
strength and turn it into weakness or
how do you take weakness and turn it
into a strength
when when
you ever heard me talk about the fact
that the SEAL Teams didn't really have a
lot of Doctrine so the Army the Marine
Corps they have Doctrine this is how you
do a raid this is how you do an assault
this is how you do an ambush they have
they had legitimate and we've covered
some of those documents on here yeah
some of those field manuals
when I first heard the first time I
heard people say that the SEAL Teams
didn't have any Doctrine it was it was
an attack
it was uh you guys don't have any
Doctrine you don't know how to do stuff
and I this was a young me younger wasn't
that young but I immediately reframed it
in a positive way not as a counter
attack but as a yeah you're right we
don't have good Doctrine on how to do
things and there's a lot of situations
where that hurts us
and if you have a new guy officer that's
never done an assault on a Target before
he has no reference point
a great great Point you're making
and that's when I had to reframe the
fact but you know
you know where it does help out
sometimes again it's a soft linear is
that
if we get tasked with a mission that not
only we not done before but no one's
done before
we've practiced creating an idea on how
to execute that mission
so even though not having Doctrine is
definitely a weakness there's also a
sense where it becomes the strength so
now all of a sudden you can't really
argue with that but it's a reframing of
the argument we do this
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jocko underground.com And subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
8.18 cents a month and if you can't
afford to support us we can still
support you just email assistance Jocko
underground.com and we'll get you taken
care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground